do I get slimed or anything at something
can I get some done gurus welcome to can
you pass is impossible 90s quiz we have
90s babies here in the house to answer
questions and test their 90s knowledge
let's give up for our contestant today I
think of the 90s I think a bomb at our
be dunkaroos favorite 90 snack you
remember the little crackers right and
they had this animal is that no known
animal kind I also think about the bomb
ass show that would happen I studied for
this and I know my mind a [ __ ] come at
me before we get started I think we need
to make sure you're fitting the 90s whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa like the Backstreet
Boys
whoa I'm sorely Saturno I'm so someone
on all that they didn't turn back in
those days right no well I'll be a
Backstreet Boy back at work the first
episode of The Fresh Prince of bel-air
90s or not can I wrap the whole
beginning for an extra point you think
it could be late
nah as the 80s came out September 10th
of 1990 open that flat top though Spice
Girls break up the first time 90s or not
how many breakups today have definitely
nine I don't think they lasted that long
Oh nah I was in 2000 I really feel like
I was still watching spice world during
the 2000 and they were still a thing
think you're gonna say no dammit I
didn't even know they started in the 80s
I thought they're starting like 94 they
started the official US release of you
can't touch this by MC Hammer 90s or not
can it be hades can't touch this is an
ad now say Alice a thing
Oh MC Hammer's not 90 nah I think it's
90 like one it was the night yeah copy
my answers you know which of these is
not one of the Hanson brothers Isaac
Garrett Zach or Taylor see their names
again cuz they all sound the same
mmm pop some from something I think I
mix it too soft
Garrett's not a very 90s me I was gonna
say to Garrett is the correct and in the
furbish language what does da a loo ooh
tie you what burmese burmese were creepy
attack what was the purpose again Oh
Malcolm you know I slept at a friend's
house once oh she had a Furby and it
kept speaking to us so we took out the
batteries and put it in her closet and
continued to talk to us came in here
very am sonam discourage right why would
I wanna / we did tell me good morning
that's not a 90s quick eight question
that's a pre question thanks for coming
out blank can you pass is it possible
nineties quiz don't forget to play
online at buzz god when they get the
last question no there has to be a bonus
round miss it